you see an empty box but she sees an
impenetrable fortress where she can
become invisible and defend the world
against the onslaught of human feet you
see a toilet seat that's been left up by
the last disgusting man that used it but
he sees he sees a magical self
replenishing fountain of a cool low
calorie and ever so slightly but scented
refreshment yeah you see a nasty puddle
that'll ruin your brand new suede
Dockers but he sees an amazing bath with
lavender oil and bubbles and rubber
ducks and a little tray so you don't
lose the soap which always seems to make
it into that awkward space between your
legs you see some IKEA drapes you hung
to make sure your neighbors wouldn't see
walk around the house naked but they see
the coolest jungle gym in the world
perfectly designed for their little
claws with a fire pole they are kind of
afraid of but you try anyway and the
tire swing and the spinny thing that
makes you want to puke you see a roll
down window that makes the car a little
too breezy when you start to drive fast
but to Hertz the coolest theme park ever
and she's on a ride called chase the
cars at Superdog speed and finally
instead of having a sticker tie out to
cool down the cool air comes to her you
see a bunch of crap ready to be taken
away to who-knows-where as long as it's
not here he sees Thanksgiving and
Passover dinner wrapped up into little
individual serving sized portions that
have had just the right amount of time
to let the flavors mingle and simmer you
see something you can't park in front of
even if you just want to jump in and get
a cup of coffee but he sees the most
glorious urinal ever erected on the face
of this earth the perfect height for
maximum coverage and who needs a urinal
meant when you love the smell of pee you
see a cheap toy you picked up in line
while buying clumping cat litter with
the hopes that you wouldn't have to
clean as awesome
but she sees a creature that's haunting
and brave and challenges the limits of
her natural dexterity patience and
imagination until it breaks then it
sucks you see the most incredible
invention that our generation is lived
to see she sees a totally useless object
that makes you very boring to be with
but happens to be super warm on her
belly you see a vacuum cleaner that's
missing the only attachment you really
but she sees the very horns of Satan
sprouting from beneath a roaring
tentacle that even HP Lovecraft couldn't
have conjured up in an apocalyptic
nightmare you see something that you
don't really want to see he sees a
portal of the best moments in life the
moment when you catch the scent of your
first girlfriends perfume or your
grandmother's apple pie a rose garden of
memories and possibility which happened
to be in a dog's ass it's all about
perspective